Triangle Square pentagon hexagon  heptagon octagon anyagon decagon  hindecagon dodecagon tridecagon  tetradecagon pentadecagon hexadecagon  hepta decagon octodecagon Ania decagon  icosagon  Circle psych that was not a circle it  was a Killian a shape with 1 000 sides  the kiliagon is famous in philosophy the  human intellect can understand the  kiliagon we can calculate their areas  and perimeters and we can separate them  from myragons which have ten thousand  sides and megagons which have a million  but human imagination is in a way more  limited in our Mind's Eye we cannot  behold each of the shapes completely and  appreciate their differences in  appearance